all right anonymous is threatening elon
musk
yeah yeah listen you're a billionaire
like he's the most beloved billionaire
like
for some reason he gets away without any
smoke yeah [ __ ] is
and maybe he's you know figured out
exactly how to do it but he gets no
smoke at all he's almost like
he's almost like uh unanimously loved
yeah and uh that shouldn't be the case
well i was like you get successful you
become a billionaire you go and get some
hate it's okay it's part of it
anonymous just sounds mad because the
[ __ ] bitcoin price is down
yeah that's probably they just sound
salty like no stop [ __ ] guys i'll be
honest with you
he is i'm not saying i don't know why i
don't hate elon
i just i see him for what he's just a
character he's playing a character
yeah i think he's gonna make all of our
lives better so i let him rock they
tried to say he didn't start tesla he
bought that [ __ ] off of somebody who
cares
i mean yeah he always tried to discredit
the inventor this guy didn't edison
didn't make the light bulb we got light
that's the most tesla show ever though
isn't it might get someone else to do it
yeah the elon musk was like
self make the business yeah he's like
i'm just gonna buy some [ __ ] that's
already popping yeah
got ripped off yeah oh because tesla got
ripped off
yeah oh scientist yeah i thought he's in
a self-driving car and he's like
he did the same [ __ ] with the business
yeah yeah the business will also make
itself
yeah yeah yeah self-driving business
that's fine it is
so that should go off again yeah with
that i don't know it's [ __ ] haunted i
think anyway
yeah i don't know it's weird but um you
know you're gonna get some smoke it is
what it is
the crazy thing was what you were saying
about his wife grimes what she tweeted
or you were saying oh yeah
she put a she put out a tick tock and
basically she was saying that ai
that communists need to embrace ai and
she was saying like how so many of her
communist friends
don't like ai for whatever reason but
actually ai is the most effective way to
get us towards
a communist state yeah that's true now
that doesn't mean that she's
a communist not necessarily but she's
saying
communists need to get on board yeah
which actually i don't
disagree with if you are a communist
yeah
no but if you're a communist that is
what's gonna ai will do all the work and
they'll just have to supplement
everybody's income
and then essentially we're all kind of
the same because the issue with
communism is that you have to have
people force farming and you're forcing
people to get out there and start doing
[ __ ] that they might not want to do but
you got to have the the village farm
but if you got ai that's able to farm
for you do all your [ __ ] for you yep
then it's actually the fastest approach
to getting a communist state in
like the philosophical sense this is the
universal basic income
pitch yeah right it's like everybody
gets enough to make a living and
survive and then you can spend your time
doing the things you actually love
yeah and it sounds good in theory but i
don't think it will work
but it is going to be tricky when ai can
do everything better than us yeah it's
also tough to take like uh
this sort of like comrade like marxist
approach to grimes who's the person that
married literally like the
metabolism yeah yeah i don't think she's
the biggest communist in the world
yeah yeah is she hot what does she look
like
no apparently not she's not do you think
that's like on do you think he's doing
that on purpose
what do you mean like i i'm just
wondering how calculated he is like is
every decision he's making about his
likability
like successful dudes with ugly wives
are immediately likable yeah but they
also named the baby like [ __ ] alpha
graphic
angels yeah which is i guess a little
annoying but like oh she's like a goth
kind of yeah
she's a scene like she's got she got a
vibe but he was with amber heard it was
a smoke show but yeah but then he was
like nah this is unlikable if i have i'm
a billionaire and i have like a smoke
show wife
people are going to hate me if i'm a
billionaire and i have a weirdo wife
like i don't i mean if he's on the
spectrum like i think he says he is
on the spectrum like it's not like he
has that deep emotional capacity
right so he's like what functions best i
mean no he does have emotional capacity
if you're autistic you think yeah
you just like aren't picking up on like
social cues and like how to like relate
to people but you don't you still feel
ah it just shows she's into all the
stuff that he's talking about like she's
an alien so he's dating something
yeah to me that seems closer like yeah
he's i'm just trying to say like
maybe he's very calculating the
decisions that he's making that's
probably true and it seems too much to
do i'm gonna have a baby with this kid
but we've seen weird things before
i can't imagine he's marrying someone
without calculating if he's calculating
every other facet of his life
yes there's a couch it has to be some
cocky i don't know what the calculation
is
tom cruise marries [ __ ] katie holmes
in like an organized wedding
yeah they have a child together they
found her yeah to marry him
it's like unbelievable things that
people do and he's not even close to as
successful as elon musk
so maybe elon is doing this thing to
create this moat around him a mode of
likeability
so i'm going to sell all my houses so i
don't have any possessions so people
can't go
he's the rich guy with all these houses
how can i make myself
um avoid as much criticism as possible
i don't have amber heard the pin-up wife
i got this weirdo chick over here that's
kind of likeable of me
right like everything that he's doing is
based on likability because the more
people like him the more that he can
manipulate the market
if he has some people hate him and some
people like him then you have the trump
effect
now you're at war constantly yeah but
the majority of people [ __ ] with you
and they're going to do what you want to
do you're a dictator with approval
rating at 90
yeah you can get a lot of [ __ ] done and
that's what
i guess we're seeing him do you getting
a lot of [ __ ] done
it's it's very interesting i'm i'm
curious about when the reckoning will
come for elon
yeah they gonna find something it's
starting this is the beginning
you think that's the beginning of this
under two i don't know what the number
is but this car will dust anything on
the road
the range is 520 miles it's the model s
model
s so a sedan that's faster than any
ferrari that's on the road right now
that's crazy
yeah insanity they changed the steering
wheel
uh or you have to get the actual
physical upgrade
i think it's the card it's the new model
you probably need
all new stuff to handle it yeah yeah so
you basically have a spaceship
yes just pay respect to our boy elon no
no there's no question
he's a he's a smooth operator the guy's
doing it but he's got some weird things
going on but maybe he's doing it
it's it's both things can be true he
could be the greatest inventor of our
lifetime
he could change the way everybody does
everything and he could be a [ __ ]
weirdo
who you know is just like a character
and everything is calculated and all
these things can all be
it's just crazy he starts at not
realizing his tweets like the dogecoin
joke that he made just but was an engine
to all of these other alt
[ __ ] coins of this pump and dump on that
stuff and he was doing it during crypto
week this weekend
with come rocket coin and blah blah blah
goods and services are the true that's
why canada
united states mexico because
if you take the first letter of each of
those it's c-u-m
and that's for come rocket the
cryptocurrency nafta
that's what it is interesting right so
he's he's having fun he's playing with
[ __ ]
kind of cool he's normally the people
who move the entire world we don't see
we don't know who they are
the [ __ ] koch brothers or whatever
this guy is moving the entire world and
we're seeing it happen in lifetime
tweets fascinating unbelievable
what about keeping on billionaires what
about bezos going to space
there's part of me that kind of likes it
and i think it's like
we need to check on on musk
i don't believe that he has nefarious
intentions but like
you need someone else it's a safety
precaution i wonder if he doesn't even
want to do it but the government is
basically like yo
can you just please do this so that we
have a safety
like a fail safe in case musk goes wild
right because we can't be
too um for lack of a word
like reliant on musk yeah if he's doing
all the space exploration
all the rockets all the missiles like
everything and then all of a sudden he
starts beefing with us
just last week you were tight that the
government was bailing them out i know
you're like i think he should i don't
know i did say at the end of it like
maybe there's good for competition
and maybe it'll be good but like part of
me starts to look at this like
does bezos want that or is bezos being
asked
to do this and when you
have a businesses that's successful
you're in business with the government
it's like you have to be especially in
america so i'm wondering if they're
doing this
just as a safety precaution because musk
is kind of a loose cannon
bezos is not bezos is let's do this
buy the book i will lobby congress i
will spend half a million dollars i'll
do this the old-fashioned way
how do we do this i've found a way to
avoid getting broken up we're clearly a
monopoly or on the way to being a
monopoly we have
a huge advantage in like the uh what is
it uh
goods business um
and and that's not being checked by the
government probably because i'm working
with them
and maybe he's doing it for them i mean
that's just me trying to understand why
right i don't know what do you guys
think i think it's possible
i think it is interesting that elon musk
could do it without but yeah to your
point like
you're in bed with the government at
that level you can't not be
so i can believe yeah i mean just go up
there just handle this
you have an empire that comes with a
cost yeah
he says he's going to be on the yeah
he's going it's kind of wild
he's bringing his brother with him
really the whole family gets taken out
what do you think faker's on death
yeah well musk shoots that [ __ ] down
you